Ah, the points I've saved up until now because of the cost of treatment
are pans.  But even if I go in
, I'm a sinful woman
I heard that a end 6 is in trouble, so hurry up If
you remember, you said that there is no friendship between men and women, right?
I thought it would be nice to say affirmatively, but I thought that if I gave you a meal normally, you wouldn't
accept it.
It
would be great if we could eat together with Endoroko-san every day from now on.
I don't have
a drink from you guys Then there should be a reason to starve to death on your own, let's fight after we
've recovered.
Thank you,
there was Kurokawa Market Isner, so I won't forget this luck
.
So what is
this beautiful princess?
Mr. Kun-san, I really wanted to get you to bow your head to vent, so this
strategy is fine, isn't it?